please father I only had the fire
nation's best interest at heart I'm
sorry it smoke out of turn will fight
for your honor
as punishment he was banished and sent
to capture the avatar only then could he
return with his honor if I have to I
will spend every day of the rest of my
life hunting the avatar I know it's my
destiny to capture him
there will be no place left to hide we
have a chance for a new life here let
the kid go
welcome back everyone is Charlie we got
a brand new Avatar The Last Airbender
Netflix teaser news about Dante Bosco
coming back for the live-action series
so this is going to be a video all about
why Prince Zuko is one of the best anti
heroes in TV history with one of the
best redemption arcs of course I'll be
doing videos for the new Avatar The Last
Airbender series when it gets here I'll
be doing bonus videos trailers teasers
Easter eggs until we get there so be
sure to subscribe to get everything so
the big news is is that Bryan and Mike
are trying to get dante basco to come
back they'll find a role for him
obviously he can't play Prince Zuko
because he's so much older now even
though his voice sounds exactly the same
as it did when he did the original voice
for Prince Zuko early speculation it'd
be more likely that he plays a minor but
significant role of someone within the
Fire Nation and because there isn't a
whole lot of Fire Nation till book 3 but
even if his role isn't that big in the
first season I think they would at least
try to get him in there for a cameo for
a little bit of fanservice and yes they
have met with a lot of the actors from
the original series but I'm not
expecting every single original team
avatar actor to come back in the new
live-action series but breaking down why
the Prince Zuko character is so
important and why he's such a master
class and character development in why
his arc was so successful whereas arcs
say like in The Game of Thrones series
with characters like Jaime Lannister
seem like they were getting a very
Prince Zuko treatment witches did not
quite stick the landing as well as
avatar the last airbenders Prince Zuko
arc the character himself is referred to
as a Webby characters that make you feel
sorry for them even if they are villains
but aren't necessarily tragic heroes the
reason why Zuko is not a tragic hero is
because his suffering is not the result
of his own actions is because of his
terrible father Fire Lord Ozai
mistreating him even though his whole
banishment at the beginning of season
one while he's searching for Aang as the
result of him speaking against Fire Lord
Ozai in court out of turn the punishment
did not fit the crime so therefore he's
not a tragic hero in the traditional
sense but he is a character that you
feel sorry for in an antihero one of the
most important things about him is his
compelling backstory that you slowly
learn about over the course of the
series
he's Aang's anomie for most of the show
up to book three he's consistently
denied approval by his father fire lord
ozai his mother left him at a young age
she had to because she killed fire lord
azulon to save Zuko's life he was only
13 when he was forced to fight his
father and given his trademark scar the
way they portrayed that scar over the
series also evolves with his character
development as well the whole reason for
his banishment the reason why he was
scarred because he spoke out against his
father and a military plan that would
have unnecessarily cost a lot of Fire
Nation lives Fire Lord Ozai wanted to
throw a bunch of troops at a problem
knowing that they would die needlessly
so Prince Zuko tried to stop him the
thing about his banishment too is that
it was actually a snipe hunt from the
beginning Fire Lord Ozai did not think
that the avatar would come back he was
effectively banishing him permanently he
never expected to see his son again you
learn a little bit of this during season
one but because of the way they portray
him in the first couple of episodes he
does come off kind of rough one of the
other key parts of his character
development is the inclusion of uncle
Iroh one of the other best TV characters
in history not just Avatar The Last
Airbender characters some would argue
that Iroh is probably the best avatar
the last airbender character but the
series is all about Aang Zuko is the
best antihero with the best Redemption
arc so it is a bit of a battle as to who
is the actual best avatar the last
airbender character their big showdown
at the end of the first season is
defined by Iroh explicitly telling Zuko
that he thinks of him as a son the
season 2 premiere ends with Aron suco
symbolically cutting their hair in their
allegiance to the Fire Nation that leads
to one of the most important episodes
for Zuko's character at the beginning of
season 2 after avatar day where he
essentially tells I rode that he's going
it alone and you get the Zuko alone
episode through the course of that
episode he finally realizes how
important Iroh is to his life and he
starts to break down this is sort of his
lowest point he has a chance to capture
Appa
but eventually lets him go this act of
mercy so it's the beginning of the rise
of Zuko the beginning of his great
Redemption art but up to this point in
the series he's so defined himself by
his Fire Nation heritage his father Fire
Lord Ozai he hates it so much he hates
himself but during these episodes he
also learns that he's
one hat descended from Avatar Roku so
that sort of represents his good HAP
that's why the scar and his face is so
important for his character development
in representative of his two dueling
halves the scar representing his Fire
Lord Ozai his Fire Nation half in the
other half representing the good half of
his character that descends from Avatar
Roku for most of the series he hates the
scar but eventually comes to terms with
both of his halves reconciles those and
no longer hides it with his hair so as
funny as it sounds his hairstyle
changing through the series does denote
his character development as it relates
to the way his scar appears on his face
his journey during season 3 is all about
him coming into his own and learning
about the larger context what it means
to rule and why what his father is doing
is wrong in what it is that he's doing
wrong he starts to understand about how
important Iroh is to his life in what he
did during Ba Sing se was wrong in how
it's not so much about aang being the
good guy is about how he wronged uncle
Iroh and how important he is to his life
as many memes have come out of the beach
episode that's actually the episode
where he finally comes to terms with how
angry he is at himself over his decision
to betray Iroh eventually he understands
everything in its fullness that's why
it's such a huge term for the character
during day the black Sun when he
officially decides to join Team Aang in
help Aang learn to fire Ben so that he
can defeat his father he's helping his
former enemy to feat his biological
father
he even has his Luke Skywalker Darth
Vader confrontation moment and comes out
of its stronger he redirects his
father's lightning and leaves to go
pursue Aang and join team avatar
he's effectively giving up everything he
thought he ever wanted before his
life-changing field trip the approval of
his father a seat at the table a chance
at the throne you have to remember that
when he was joining team aang he wasn't
sure that they would ultimately be
successful so he didn't know that they
would win and he would eventually become
the Fire Lord and right there at the end
the ember island players probably the
best recap episode of any TV series ever
it's great just as an episode by itself
it allows the characters to reflect on
their journey primarily with Zuko and
then with a little bit of help from Toph
to reflect on his journey realize that
Iroh
loved and supported him this whole time
then the two are finally reunited in the
series finale and Iroh silences Zuko's
apologies with this tearful hug one of
the most emotionally satisfying moments
on the entire show in the thing that
makes the payoff at the end of the
season with him becoming Fire Lord and
joining hands with his former enemy Aang
in Brotherhood is that he's always
struggled for everything nothing is
giving to him easy even at the very end
when he's forced to face his sister
Azula and eventually takes pity on her
he's chosen the things that are most
important to him sacrificed his pride
dignity and his beliefs along the way to
find his Redemption it just shows you
how down to earth and human he really is
but also how powerful the arc is that's
what makes the payoff so meaningful for
his character at the end of the series
so let me know in the comments why do
you think that Prince Zuko is one of the
most compelling characters in TV history
and who is your favorite avatar the last
airbender character and I know there's a
lot of concern because the Netflix
series is going to be a live-action
avatar retelling of the original story
but just remember that it's the original
creators in a lot of the original team
that are coming back to make these
episodes make it in the way that it
should be made and because this is a
Zuko video primarily here's Dante Bosco
reacting to the live-action avatar the
last airbender movie he says about what
you would expect him to say for most
movie don't only know the series
it's one of those things like so it's
hard and then young directors you know
they really want with their fingerprints
on the project it's just hard when
you're going it's a really big project
like no one like no one wants you to
take Star Wars and change Luke
Skywalker's name until I know I know
people tell me like eggs name is like
why did you do that it's more it's more
correct it's more correct it's funny to
hear him talk about the movie that way
he's sort of tiptoeing around things in
his political as way as possible trying
to explain yeah it's not a good movie
without openly demonizing and Knight too
much because a lot of the people he
tangentially might wind up working with
later on you might wind up costing him
some jobs but he is trying to say that
yeah it was definitely not a good movie
and because of all the Netflix marketing
stuff that'll be going on next year I
wouldn't be surprised if you hear them
getting asked a lot of questions about
how this is going to be different from the
live-action movie like how will this be
better please explain to us I will keep
doing Avatar The Last Airbender bonus
videos this year there should be some
more news about the Netflix series soon
we'll hear about casting who's going to
be the new avatar aang who's going to be
there Prince Zuko right now I believe
they're finishing their scripts and then
they're probably finished their casting
before the end of the year maybe early
next year
we should have some pretty big news
relatively soon while you wait for
everything click here for all my avatar
the last airbender videos and click here
for the brand-new Rick and Morty season
4 teaser trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight!